[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF WETZLER: I want
to start by showing you
a few images that have
nothing to do with education.
If you were to enter some
keywords into Google--
for example, if
you were to enter,
"surgery in the
early 20th century,"
you might see an image
like this one here.
And if you were to then
say, "What about the 1950s?"
you might see an image like
this, where it changes.
And if you were to say
the 2000's or beyond,
you would see a
pretty different image
of what the delivery
of medicine looks
like over the course
of hundred years or so.
Similarly, if you were to
say media or communications,
you might see something
like this in the 1900s.
And you might see something
like this in the 1950s.
And you'd see something
quite different in the 2000s.
If you go to
transportation, something
like this in the 1900s,
cars in the 1950s,
planes and beyond now.
Now, I want to apply
it to classrooms.
If you were to do the
same thing and you
were to enter into Google,
"classrooms in the 1900s,"
you might see
something like this.
If you were to enter 1950s, you
might see something like this.
And if you were to
enter today, you
would see something like this.
And one of the observations
that animates the work that we
do at Transcend is that
those images are not
particularly different.
And when we think about how
vastly society has changed
in almost every other sector,
in terms of how things are
delivered, you see
a stark contrast
with what you would
see in education.
So here comes the first part
of our interactive discussion.
I want to give you a challenge.
And I like to do
this with groups
and just see, if you were to
look at these three images,
how many features
of school can you
find that are consistent
across these time periods?
And so a "feature" could
be something like the fact
that there are desks and
kids are sitting at desks
and those desks are pointing
to the front of the room.
So you can use that
one to get you started.
But just take a moment
to think about that.
And then when you
think of a feature
that you notice is unchanged,
just raise your hand,
and I'll toss you
the microphone.
Yeah, great.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Every
student has notebooks--
traditional notebooks
or schoolwork
on their desk versus technology.
JEFF WETZLER: Great.
Thanks for getting us started.
What else?
Over here.
AUDIENCE: One-to-many-- so
one teacher at the front
with multiple students.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
So there's sort of a
broadcast kind of a mode.
Like, the teacher's got it,
the teacher's broadcasting.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Class sizes
are basically the same.
JEFF WETZLER: Class sizes--
so somewhere between 20
and 30 or 40 kids in a
room as part of a class.
Can you catch this?
OK.
AUDIENCE: There's no space
really for group interaction.
All the kids are
just looking forward.
And they aren't grouped at all.
JEFF WETZLER: Right.
And so that's
conditioning a certain way
of working and engaging.
You want to toss it over there?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, my bad.
JEFF WETZLER: And who's next?
Because I'll be ready
for the next one.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So there's
still a classroom.
JEFF WETZLER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: There's
still a classroom.
JEFF WETZLER: There's
It has walls.
It is a room.
You're inside that room.
AUDIENCE: All the
kids in the classroom
are all about the same age.
JEFF WETZLER: The
kids are grouped.
They're batched
almost, you could
say, in roughly the
same age in the room.
How about one or two more?
Thank you.
That's all right.
Any last observations?
OK.
AUDIENCE: The classrooms
don't have a lot of windows.
There's a lot of walls.
They're very closed in,
in terms of [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
There's almost like a
separation between learning
and the real world or learning
and the outside world.
I appreciate that.
Good.
OK.
Let's do two more--
these two over here.
One-- thanks.
AUDIENCE: The kids
would appear to be
engaged in the same
task at the same time.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
So unlike where you might
see maybe an office here,
where people are working
on their own thing
or doing their own
thing, everyone's
kind of being asked to do the
same thing at the same time.
AUDIENCE: I see diversity.
There's not much ethnic
diversity in the classroom.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
There's kind of sameness,
or you might even
say separation or segregation
in terms of the populations
in the room, as well.
Some groups get
100, 200 features
that you could imagine.
But it's really
striking, when you
think about the differences in
all these other sectors, just
the number of features
that really are unchanged.
One of the things that
we often talk about
are that systems achieve what
they're designed to achieve.
And so you could look at this
as a system that's been designed
to achieve something.
And you might even say it
is achieving what it's been
designed to achieve, as well.
And so the next question
I want to just open up
for conversation is, if we were
to almost reverse engineer,
what is the system
designed to achieve?
If you were to try
to design a system
to achieve a set of
outcomes and that system
had all the features
that you just
named in it, in terms of kids
that maybe looked roughly
the same age, facing a teacher,
inside a room that's separated
from the outside world--
those are design features,
you could almost imagine.
What's the outcome?
So what outcome do you think
that this type of system
is designed to achieve, whether
for kids or for society?
AUDIENCE: Conformity.
JEFF WETZLER: Conformity.
OK.
Can you say a little
bit more about that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It appears to be a very
uniform environment.
They're all doing
the same thing.
It seems like it's
a very narrow scope.
There's not much room
for differentiation
as an individual person
in these environments.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
So it's almost
like it's designed
to socialize people
to be a certain way
and to act a certain way and to
maybe even conform to authority
or follow directions or
different things like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This
actually piggybacks
on what he just said, but it's
almost like an assembly line.
It's like it's
training people to,
you would assume, to do the
exact same thing when they
get out of this environment.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
And so it's helping
almost masses of people
be ready to do kind of
standardized types of jobs.
The other thing that I think
is relevant about the assembly
line point is that it's
also a very efficient way
to get lots of people in.
And so this model
came about at a time
when we needed to take
lots and lots of kids
who might have been in rural
communities or not in school.
And it's been a very,
very efficient model
to give lots and lots of
people access to education.
Ready?
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's also
kind of designed
to build competition
internally, because everyone's
learning the same things.
Everyone's doing the same thing.
So you want to see who's
different, but not really
different, just more
competitive in the same aspect.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
So it's designed almost
to create an individual,
individualistic orientation
in people-- like,
how do I get ahead--
as contrasted with maybe a
more collaborative teamwork
kind of orientation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It teaches
the students--
or it trains the students to
receive information rather than
generate it or question it--
that sort of mono-directional
[INAUDIBLE] transfer.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
It's basically training
and conditioning people
to be passive recipients.
Take it in from somebody else
who has the answer, as opposed
to generating the
answer yourself.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Also, I think--
I don't know the
right way to word
this-- but to maintain
the status quo,
it's easy for educators and for
school districts-- the system's
already in place,
so it's easy just
to keep doing what they've
been doing for a long time.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
And you could think about
that on many levels--
maintaining the status quo in
terms of how schools function,
how societies function,
how power is distributed
in society-- a whole range of
different aspects of the status
quo that can get preserved
when you take a bunch of people
and say, conform, listen,
there's an authority figure--
all of that.
Absolutely.
Good.
So I want to ask
you, if you think
about all these
different outcomes
that you just identified that
school is preparing people for
and you would contrast
that with what it takes
to be successful at Google,
just as an example, what
are your observations?
What are your reflections about
similarities or differences
between what our
mainstream model of school
is setting people
up to do and what
it takes to be successful
in an environment like here?
Ready?
AUDIENCE: I'd say it
contrasts in the way
that here, we reward
strategic thinking,
thinking outside of the box,
going against the status quo,
thinking outside of--
developing cutting-edge ideas,
whereas this is not that.
This is conforming to a single
form of teaching and receiving.
JEFF WETZLER: Yes.
So if the whole point
is that we actually
need to think beyond today,
think beyond the box,
and yet we're teaching
kids inside a box
to follow authority
and listen to a teacher
and take things
in and not create,
there's a really important
gap or contrast there.
Thanks for starting that.
Other reflections
or observations?
Ready?
AUDIENCE: Here at
Google, you kind of
have to explore your
own solutions a lot more
and figure them out.
And then if you need help,
you ask the authority on how
to guide you, whereas in
the classroom environment,
it's more like, hey, I
don't know the answer.
And then someone tells
you what the answer is.
JEFF WETZLER: There's
someone who has the answer.
And their job is
to give it to you,
and your job is to
take it from them
and do something with
it, as opposed to you've
got to figure out how to
navigate your own path
and find your own answer.
Absolutely.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I disagree
[INAUDIBLE] with other answers.
JEFF WETZLER: Can you
just talk into here?
Sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I disagree a
little bit with [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFF WETZLER: Say more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think especially
at junior levels--
actually even at senior levels--
you're given an assignment,
and you have to complete it.
And school is very good
at making people receive
an assignment and complete it.
JEFF WETZLER: Yep.
So there are ways in
which this actually
does set you up to be
able to take direction,
follow direction, do it.
Good.
Any reactions to that or other
comments or observations?
AUDIENCE: I think
a core difference
in the kinds of assignments
we would get here
is that we have many unknown
unknowns in which there
might be no one to go out
and get the answer from.
You would need to dig in
and actually find the answer
to an abstract problem.
And that doesn't really
fit into the kind of model
that you would normally get
in a classroom assignment
in a traditional school.
JEFF WETZLER: So while it may
be true that school sets you up
to do assignments, what's the
nature of the assignment that's
required here?
I think that's important.
Yes?
Did you also have one?
AUDIENCE: I would
also say, even when
people are given
assignments at Google,
it's understood that you might
possibly go back and say,
we need to change the
parameters of this assignment.
It's not necessarily
set in stone.
Or you might find
something to be impossible,
whereas in a school,
you can't just--
if you get math homework,
you can't declare your math
homework to be impossible
or think you need
to do different math homework.
JEFF WETZLER: Right.
So you actually might
almost be expected
to question the
assignment or to change
the parameters of
the assignment,
et cetera, which is often
not the case at school.
You're sort of
evaluated and graded on,
did I do the assignment as
given within those parameters?
Great.
AUDIENCE: So I want to take
a maybe less cynical approach
and think that maybe the
system, if you contextualize it
with the scarcity of information
that's available around you
at that time, is actually
a really efficient system
to get people to integrate
well with society
with a baseline of knowledge
that's difficult-- now
with the internet and access
to libraries and resources,
you can say that,
OK, yeah, we need
better sources of information.
We need more different
styles of learning.
But I think this is probably
the best that we could do.
JEFF WETZLER: At the
time, you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
Did you want to react to that?
AUDIENCE: And even
in most places now,
it's probably still
the best we can do.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
if I can kind of
rephrase what you're
saying-- tell me
if you think this is accurate.
But basically,
you're saying, this
is a system that is really
well-designed for people
who don't have a really large
amount of knowledge compared
to the people they're
interacting with,
like their teachers,
compared to Google,
where you expect that
everyone has a really
high baseline of knowledge.
AUDIENCE: And that
baseline of knowledge
is garnered from some place.
JEFF WETZLER: And that
baseline of knowledge
is garnered from some place.
Yeah.
And I think
particularly at the time
when this model came
about, to your point,
when information was scarce,
when it wasn't democratically
distributed, when we
couldn't take out our phones
and look up many, many
different things--
it was really efficient
to have somebody who has
the information to pass it on.
And also to your point,
that's true in certain places
at certain moments, as well.
But it's also true
that information
is far more available now.
And knowledge is
far more available
than it ever was before.
And I think that's a good segue.
Our core observation
is that we've
got a delivery model of
schooling that was perfectly
designed for a time
that's now passed.
And so the question is, what are
the kinds of shifts and changes
that we would need to make in
our education delivery model
and schooling, so to
speak, to actually
make it more relevant
to be able to foster
in kids the kinds of
habits and competencies
and things like that
that you all described
were necessary to thrive
at a place like Google,
and also, maybe more broadly,
to even change the world in ways
that we don't even
know yet right now?
So within our own
organization, Transcend,
we think about a set of what
we call leaps that we think
that schools need to make.
I won't go through them all.
But they include things like,
what's school going after?
In a world where
knowledge was scarce,
learning a lot of things and
learning a lot of knowledge
was important.
In a world where we can now
access lots of knowledge,
we need to learn how to create.
We need to learn how to
question assignments.
change parameters, et cetera.
So this first leap
is literally even
the objectives of
what's going on.
The third one on
the list is around,
what's the role of the student?
Is the student a
passive recipient,
or is the student
someone who's actually
going to take charge of
their own learning, someone
who's going to actually chart
their own path, et cetera?
Several of you noticed
that in the pictures,
there was one teacher
to many students.
And often, that teacher has to
wear many, many different hats.
They have to instruct.
They have to tend
to social needs.
They have to meet kids
who might be behind.
They have to challenge kids
who are ahead, et cetera.
Why does it have to be that way?
We actually could
differentiate roles
of adults who could play many
different roles, some of which
are teachers, some of which may
be people who technically work
outside the school.
We didn't talk a
lot about parents,
but one of the
things that we didn't
see in any of the pictures
was family members
or parents or caregivers.
And the traditional
design of school
often keeps parents and
family members at a distance
and sort of says, the
teacher's here to do the work,
you guys can do whatever
you want to do, et cetera.
So there's a number
of different leaps
that we hypothesize need
to happen for schools to be
producing kids that are going
to be more ready for where
the world is today and
what the future demands.
I think it's probably more
helpful and more compelling
for me to show you what
some of those things
look like in action, as opposed
to try to describe them.
So I want to show you just
a couple of short videos
that actually put this in the
words of kids and educators,
because I think
the way that we're
going to make these
leaps is going to be,
kids are going to lead
us there, educators
are going to lead
us there, schools
are going to lead us there.
So I want to show you
a couple of videos.
And after each video, I want
to ask you to just be thinking
about, what do you notice here?
What strikes you as
potentially different?
And what's the
significance of that?
So maybe be thinking
about that question.
This first video
is from a partner
that Transcend started working
with several years ago called
Achievement First,
who runs schools
in New York and Connecticut
and Rhode Island.
And they wanted to
rethink the school--
they wanted to rethink
their school model
to basically produce
the kinds of outcomes
that you all were talking about
so that their kids could really
be the best-prepared
kids in the world.
And one dimension of the
school model has to do with,
how do we put kids at the center
of pursuing their own dreams
and goals?
So whereas a traditional
design of school
is almost irrespective of
what a kid's unique dreams
and goals is--
it's like, what's the
teacher doing, what do
we have to study, et cetera--
in this design project, we
said, what if we flipped that?
What if the kid was at
the center, and then
everything else
was trying to say,
how do we help that
kid's dreams come true?
So you won't see
the total model,
but you hear a little
bit about this.
And then I'm interested
in your observations.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- When we really think
about scholars as a whole
and their strengths and
the things that they love
and the people that they love,
bringing us all to the table
is just so powerful.
It says that we care
about you here at school,
we care about you beyond school.
And I think that that sends
the message with Dream Team.
- But today, we're going to
be discussing my strengths.
I think empathy means
having love for others,
it caring for others, helping
others out when they need it.
Sometimes when I'm around
my grandma, I see how she--
she believes in God.
I do, too.
But she, like, really
believes in God.
And she's always helping others,
either if it's-- at least
giving someone some money.
You do that, too, Daddy.
You give me some money
to give to the homeless.
- The concept of
the Dream Teams is
trying to have more
student agency,
to have them be the drivers
of what's important to them
in life, because what we've
learned over the years
is that, at some point,
the school falls away.
Even many of the adults
become at least less present
in a daily way in a kid's life.
They go off to college.
They go off into the world.
And they've got to have
a sense of self that's
going to carry them forward.
- Hello, and welcome to
my Dream Team meeting.
This is a place where
I share my goals,
and I tell you my dreams
and the strengths that
make me to be me.
I'm grateful that
you guys came here
to spend your time
to hear my dream--
- The experiences that I've
noticed with the children--
they all bring a
little something into--
a little piece of
themselves into it.
And they run the
meetings themselves.
So it's nice to see my children
actually speaking out and just
adding their own personalities
to their own meetings.
- Thank you.
- The purpose of Dream Teams
are to be more student-led
and student-centered.
So scholars get an
opportunity where
they get to shine in the
meeting to, A, practice
their public speaking
abilities and to actually
own their progress.
- It's really hard to
pass [INAUDIBLE] week,
because you have to be at
the top of one of the sticks.
Five.
So there's bars that
you have to finish.
And there's-- there's sometimes
seven seven [INAUDIBLE]
- I see improvement from
the last Dream Team meeting.
- I do.
- Definitely.
- Especially in
the speaking loud.
No?
- We've also seen that
in class, as well--
just improved speaking out loud.
- When my goal was to get to
mission 5 last [INAUDIBLE]
on the Dream Team meeting,
and I finished third.
- [? Anoah ?] knows
what her goals are--
academic goals,
her passion goals.
And [? Anoah ?] is driving
towards those on her own.
So she's the one that's saying,
oh, I need computer time,
or I want a computer so
I can do my math at home.
- Can you tell us a
little bit about why
you're choosing curiosity?
- Because I want to
be focused in STEM
and ask lots of questions.
And then I can
probably be an engico--
engineer.
- Well, I think when
we started opening up
just with simple
questioning, ways
to get families more
engaged in the conversation,
the investment grew.
And family partnerships
grew as a result of that.
- All my Dream Team
parents have my number.
I get text messages
with screenshots, hey,
is this the homework they're
supposed to be working on?
And I think we kind of
get rid of that barrier
where they don't feel
comfortable talking to me.
So I think the purpose is
really to make everyone
on the same team.
- --they give you feedback?
- They gave me feedback,
because feedback is a gift.
- There we go.
Yes.
- What means a lot to me is
that my dad and my sister
are here to set goals for me
and improve on what I'm doing.
- What about the places you
think we need to set goals?
- In reading, you said
that you are proficient.
I'd like to see you advanced
by the end of the year,
because reading is
pretty important.
So I want you to try
harder with reading.
- Right there, can
you explain to me
what the picture
represent for you?
- You see scholars
who get up there
and really feel confident and
have a clear focus on what
their goals are and what
their strengths are,
and that just feels really good.
- My parent was able to see
what I did and how my strengths.
- We are building transferable
life skills for scholars here.
It is really important that
they can be strong scholars
and academic geniuses.
But it's more
important that they
develop into really
strong little people that
will become big people that
will impact their communities.
And I think that the
life habits that we're
building in scholars, in terms
of their personal growth,
the empathy they
show for themselves,
for others, the drive and
persistence that they will need
to persist to and
through college,
and to just learn more
about who they are as people
so that they can be
stronger at what they're
driving towards in life--
and that is super powerful.
And I just wish more
schools were doing that.
- Like you just was
talking, you never give up.
Keep doing hard work
and complete your goals.
[END PLAYBACK]
Cool.
So I wanted to just ask you
all, in addition to how cute
the kids are, what did you
notice when you contrast that
to some of the kind of
images of school and concepts
that we talked about?
You want to start here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I wasn't sure
how heavy that was.
I loved that the kid was
sitting in the big chair,
and everyone was
sitting around them.
And they were the boss.
It reminds me of "Boss
Baby"-- the books.
And I'm like, yep, that's
my house right there.
JEFF WETZLER: Can you say what
you think the significance
of that might be?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Oh, sure.
Yes.
So to me, it felt like
they were in control.
And they were presenting.
And everybody else
was listening to them.
And I thought that was just
so respectful to the child.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
It really intends to flip
who's in charge of one's
learning here in the situation.
Good.
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Anybody else have
an observation,
something that struck you?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I know earlier,
you've gone from many children
to one educator, and
now you have one child,
many people working with them.
JEFF WETZLER: Exactly.
So one of the other things
that Dream Teams does--
a lot of Dream Teams will
have parents or maybe
an aunt or an uncle or grandma
or a pastor or a coach.
There's a lot of adults in kids'
lives who have a lot to offer
and who have a lot
of love for kids.
And the typical design of
school kind of leaves that all
on the sidelines and says it's
the job of a teacher, which,
by the way, puts a ton
of pressure on teachers
and makes teachers'
jobs super, super hard.
If we could actually flip
that and tap into all the love
that's around a kid--
you could even see that
the sister who was saying,
I have something
to offer to you,
I want to challenge
you, as well--
imagine what becomes
possible when you open up
all those other resources
that are typically
sidelined right now.
AUDIENCE: Just an observation--
everything in those
interactions was so positive.
And if you think about
parent-teacher conferences,
or if you get called
by the school,
you're going to talk about
what your kid is doing,
oftentimes it is only because
something bad is happening,
or there needs to be an
intervention or remediation.
And in this case, it was
the opposite of that.
And so I just think
that was great.
JEFF WETZLER: Awesome.
Thanks.
Let's take one more, if
there's any last comment.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
my observation was
that it was very goal-oriented.
If you ask my 8-year-old,
"What are your goals,"
he would have no idea
what you're talking about,
number one.
And number two was,
parent-teacher conferences,
like you said, you're talking
about the child instead
of involving the child
in the conversation.
When we asked the teacher,
"Should the child come,"
they're like, no,
you guys are fine.
We're just going to
talk about the child.
JEFF WETZLER: As if the
child's participation
in their own learning isn't
maybe the most important thing.
Right.
Exactly.
I think it recognizes
that kids do have dreams.
And kids do have goals.
And it's possible to tap into
them if we re-orient the way
that school is structured.
So I want to just
show you one, maybe
two other clips of older kids.
So this next one is an example
from a partner of Transcend's
called Valor Collegiate,
which is based in Nashville,
Tennessee but now
has a model that is
spreading all over the country.
And among the eight great
leaps that I talked about,
the first one was
around, really,
what is school going after.
And so what Valor
is saying is, if we
were to go beyond
academics, if we're
trying to help kids actually
build skills related
to relationships, skills
related to knowing themselves,
skills related to their
identity, which is going to be
pretty important, given
the diversity of the world
and workplaces and
how often they're
going to need to reinvent
themselves, potentially,
as the economy changes--
what would it take?
What would it look
like to actually build
that in scholars, in kids?
And they have tried
to integrate academics
with a lot of the
really interesting youth
development and even
therapeutic practices
that you might see when
kids are sharing in circles.
And so in this model, kids have
a whole curriculum that they
self-direct through, where they
go through a set of different
kinds of exercises--
you'll see one here--
at their own pace,
at their own time,
but then bring that to
share it in a group.
And it's actually the
group that decides
has the kid done the
work, and does the kid get
to progress and go forward?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I would title my life
"Going Through the Struggles."
And my mom said that she would
name it "The Butterfly Reaching
the Top of the Mountain."
And then my dad said
"Overcoming the Challenges."
And Miss Hodge said
"The Joy in the Storm."
The story's about my family.
We're Muslim.
And we moved here pretty early.
But we were all
born in Kurdistan.
And a lot of people ask us about
how it's like, where's better--
here or Kurdistan--
and they really ask about
the food and how we make it.
Something that
really surprised me
was what my dad
one time told me--
that I put my mind
to everything,
and when I do that, I
accomplish my goals.
So when I was in
my last school, I
didn't really share
anything about myself,
because I was shy that
they would make fun of me.
But now I feel
really comfortable
with my [INAUDIBLE].
And I named my life "Going
Through the Struggles,"
because there's a situation
back in Kurdistan.
And I [INAUDIBLE].
[CRYING] And it's
hard to do this
because I still [INAUDIBLE].
It's really hard
to go through this.
And I really wouldn't
change anything about me,
because it's my identity.
And I want to be who I am.
And I wouldn't be who
I am without you guys
or without my family.
So thank you.
- Lana, thank you for
sharing your life story.
I saw a lot of love being
sent to Lana as she shared.
That was very brave.
Are there any resonances,
anything that stuck
with you in Lana's life story?
Pearl?
- I understand how difficult
it must be, because--
I've never moved from
country to country.
So I can't relate
with you with that.
But I have moved around
a lot in my life.
And we have been insanely poor.
And we've also been
mildly rich before.
But we've had so many ups
and lows with our family.
And I could connect
with you with that,
because I understand how hard
it is going from place to place
and just how difficult
it is to deal with that.
And I understand that.
I understand, and
I also appreciate
that you have the
courage to say that
in front of a lot of people.
I understand.
[END PLAYBACK]
Similarly, I'm just interested
in thoughts and observations.
Imagine that this
was a part of school,
that these kinds of experiences
happened literally every week
with kids sharing, bringing
this kind of vulnerability,
building these kinds
of relationships
across lines of difference.
What did you notice here?
And what might be
significant about it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The immediate
acceptance and love
she felt from her peers after
sharing her brief story, which
I think is counter to what
you hear about schools today.
Kids are bullies.
Kids are mean.
They are not nice to each other.
And you could really
see the connection
amongst the students.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
And what do you see as
significant about that?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's teaching them
a skill set to be
accepting and loving
at a very young
age and connection
to their personal identity, to
not be ashamed of who they are.
Yeah.
JEFF WETZLER: Absolutely.
These are things that
are not the typical aim.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Literally, the question
I wanted to ask you
is, how old are these kids?
Because I, as a
28-year-old woman,
don't even feel that
connected to my identity.
It's pretty crazy to see
[INAUDIBLE] speak so proudly.
JEFF WETZLER: Exactly.
It shows what's possible
when we ask this of kids
and we offer them
the opportunity
to do this kind of work.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to--
just something that's super
just core and super basic--
just the way that the
room is structured.
And in a traditional classroom,
all the students are facing.
One student is front of the
class, which can be actually
really intimidating.
And I just liked
how the students
were sitting in a circle,
because it's not like,
oh, I'm not--
I'm with you.
I'm not against you.
I'm not here to judge you.
I'm here with you.
I'm listening.
And I like how when kids are--
they're listening thoughtfully.
They're listening curiously
and responding thoughtfully.
And when they do that,
I like how they get up,
and they actually are physically
engaging with the person
to relate to them.
So I thought that was
super interesting, as well.
JEFF WETZLER: Thank you.
Yeah.
And such a contrast
to some of the images
we saw earlier about
the traditional design.
I think you make a really
important point about space,
as well, What does that say
about who matters and why
and all of it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I like that
there was a established way
to provide real-time feedback
with their finger waves.
They're getting that
instant validation
while they're speaking.
JEFF WETZLER: Exactly.
The kind of rituals and
routines and protocols.
And I that brings up an
important point, which
is, it's not enough just to
say, let's put kids in a circle.
Let's just see what happens.
Every aspect of it is
a design challenge.
All those rituals and different
things like that were designed.
And someone built those, and
someone prototyped those,
and someone tested
those to the point
where they felt like
this can actually work.
And so I think it
illustrates some
of what we would refer to as the
R&D required to actually build
this in schools.
AUDIENCE: I guess one
question I have for you--
because the presentation is
structured as schools don't
do this, and we should do it.
And I've had a little bit
of a different experience
in our public
school system, where
they do have a psychologist
that comes in and grabs
a group of kids and
brings them to a room
and has conversations like this.
So I guess my question for you--
school's changed a lot
since I've been there.
How do you see public
schools-- are they moving
into this direction?
Are they starting to
implement these features?
Or is it region by
region or the more
progressive regions
are doing things
like this, where there's
others that are more
"behind the times," I guess?
JEFF WETZLER: There's
definitely variation.
And I'm glad you raised it.
I think that there's all kinds
of really promising practices
and pilots and innovations that
even individual teachers are
doing in their classrooms,
schools are trying, et cetera.
And all of that is
really positive.
And I think we want to
essentially put wind
at the back of all of those
different kinds of efforts.
And yet, at the same
time, oftentimes they
get constrained, because they're
operating still in the core
underlying structure of school.
And so one of the things that
we work on-- and I'll talk about
this more in a moment--
is, how do we
actually fully release
some of those
constraints so that more
of these kinds of
experiences can be possible
for kids and for educators?
Any last comments on this?
Yes, we'll take this
as the last comment.
AUDIENCE: I really like
that it has to do with--
we focus on academic
development.
But really, this is about
development of yourself,
which I think is a
really great focus.
I think in terms of a
really diverse country,
we often face--
we're talking about
diversity as we're older
and trying to
solve those issues.
But if you focus on
it at a younger age--
as a first generation
Asian-American,
I tried to hide that
part of me growing up,
because that's who you
are when you're a child.
You're trying to fit in.
And so if we can embrace who we
are and bring it all together
at a younger age, can
we conquer the issues
with diversity in the long term?
So I think this is amazing.
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
We see and experience
and hear so much right
now in our country
and in our world
about divides and polarization.
And if we can
actually have schools
be a place where kids are
actually learning that they can
bring their whole selves and
cross bridges and respect
one another, et
cetera, how much better
could the world be
if we could do that
starting from a young age?
I really appreciate that point.
And also, I think,
to your point,
even if all we were caring
about was academic achievement--
which we believe is only part
of what needs to matter--
but even if that was all
we were caring about,
what we're starting to find is
that these kinds of experiences
can allow kids to
be in school more
in what we call their
executive state, as opposed
to their survival state.
So if kids are feeling
traumatized or kids are feeling
not free to be themselves, that
gets in the way of learning,
because that's what they're
going to be thinking about,
as opposed to thinking about
what's going on actually
in the content.
And so both to improve even
academic learning and then
for all the reasons
you just said,
these kinds of
experiences really matter.
If we had more time, I
was hoping to show you--
but we can send some links
afterwards-- some older
examples, as well.
So there's actually a
really exciting partner that
we're working with in Brooklyn
called Brooklyn STEAM,
which is basically a hub model,
where kids from lots of other
different schools come and spend
a good chunk of their junior
and senior year learning
STEAM-related content,
but embedded in the
Brooklyn Naval Yard so that
they're actually doing the
real work of coding, of design,
of culinary arts-- a range
of different things--
with employers and can graduate
not just with a high school
degree but also with a social
network, which really matters,
and also with real
skills that they
can use to earn money during
college, before college,
after college-- all those
different kinds of things.
And so it's a really
exciting model
that, if you're
interested, I would even
encourage you all to check out.
And there's a whole bunch
of other ones, as well.
We didn't talk as much
about technology here.
But a lot of interesting models
are really engaging and using
technology not just to
help kids access content,
but to actually
create and communicate
with ways to learn far beyond
the walls of the school,
as well.
I thought I would take
just a couple minutes
and share with you about
our organization, Transcend.
Our mission is to enable
communities to imagine, create,
and spread these kinds of
learning environments--
extraordinary
learning environments,
equitable learning environments.
And we do that really by playing
two major roles in the field.
One is that we're
trying to increase
the supply of great options.
So we just showed you
snippets out of two models.
But we're trying to increase
the supply of options of what
we call catalytic models--
models that are getting
great results-- not just
academic results,
but the other kinds
of results that we were
just talking about.
Sometimes we talk about
the triple wow factor.
So one wow is kids
wow-- like, wow,
I cannot wait to come to
school, I cannot wait to learn,
this is exciting.
A second wow is
the families' wow--
like, this is so good for
my kid, I love my kid,
my kid is loved, they are
growing, they're challenged,
it's rigorous.
And the third is educators,
because the traditional design
of school is not easy
for educators, as well.
So if we can create models that
are getting verified results
but also having this
triple wow factor,
that's one piece of what
we call a catalytic model.
A second is that
it sparks demand.
And so all of these
examples, and many others
that we work with, people
see them and they say,
we want that in our
communities, as well.
And so that's part of
creating the wave of change,
to accelerate it, to your point.
And the third are,
can they be codified
in ways that make it sharable?
So to the point of, even
all those little rituals
and different things like that,
someone had to think them up.
Someone had to write them down.
Someone had to try
them, et cetera.
There's no reason
why everyone has
to reinvent the wheel on that.
How do we codify that
so that other people
can borrow from that?
So one piece of
what Transcend does
is, we work deeply with
partners across the country that
work with young people to try
to create these catalytic models
so that there are more
options for communities
that they can learn from, be
inspired by, and borrow from.
The second role that
we play is that we're
supporting a broader
range of communities
everywhere to build their demand
and readiness for this work.
So to the point that
you raised, there
is some of this happening.
And that's great.
But we actually think there's
even more latent demand,
like what kids actually want,
the dreams that they actually
have, what parents
want, et cetera.
We've started to realize
that we can actually
work with communities to
build a set of conditions that
accelerate their movement
in this direction--
things like conviction
about what really matters;
clarity about, what are the
kinds of aims beyond just
knowledge that they
want to be building;
things like a culture
of innovation,
like you all have here, in
terms of let's try something,
let's learn from it, let's
keep iterating, et cetera;
things like a coalition.
So it's not just one
person leading it,
but the change can
actually sustain,
because parents are part of it,
and employers are part of it,
committee members are
part of it, et cetera.
So these are essentially
the two kinds of roles
that we're trying to play.
And these are just some
examples of partners
that we're working with
on both of those fronts.
We work with districts.
We work with charter schools.
We work with
independent schools who
are doing this incredible
innovation work.
And the hope is that
if we can both grow
the demand and the readiness,
as well as grow the supply,
we can start to build bridges
so that when a community says,
all right, now we're ready--
we can say, oh, here's
a model over here.
We can help make
it faster for them
to move in that type of
direction, if that makes sense.
And we do that by trying to
invest in three capabilities
or assets in our organization.
One is a set of design
expertise and tools.
So we have a whole bunch
of people on our team
who work directly with schools
and are building a set of tools
that they can use to go through
design processes to learn this.
Two is that we're
building a knowledge hub.
So there's a lot to learn about
what works, what doesn't work,
in what contexts, et cetera.
How do we apply
learning science,
the science of cognition,
neuroscience, et cetera?
We don't want to just do
this kind of innovation
willy-nilly, do brainstorming.
There's a lot that we can learn.
And so we're building
a hub of knowledge
that people can draw from.
And then the third is a network,
where we actually have schools
across the country, funders
across the country, talent,
researchers, et cetera.
We've seen that
change moves fastest
when networks are involved.
And so we're building
this network, as well.
Those are the three pieces
of what we're trying to do.
Any questions or thoughts,
reactions, comments?
AUDIENCE: So I'm
interested in when
you said it's codified
to make it shareable.
You want it to be so people
don't have to reinvent
the wheel every time.
[INAUDIBLE] makes sense.
How are you doing that?
Where do you store your
content slash curriculum slash
resources, materials,
and whatnot?
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah,
great question.
It's a combination
of different media.
So some of it is stuff
that we write down
in documents-- lots
of Google Docs.
Some of it is
videos that we use.
technology platforms
that people actually start
to interact with things,
directly using the technology.
And some of it is actually
codified through the form
of learning experiences.
So for example, that second
video that we showed,
there's a set of training
and learning experiences
that people can come to
to learn how to facilitate
that kind of work.
So it's multiple different
kinds of media that we use.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
JEFF WETZLER: Great.
AUDIENCE: Building
on that question,
are you typically seeing more
of a bottoms-up approach,
in the sense of
teachers or educators
who are ready to
kind of transcend
or go to that next level?
Or is it top-down with the
administrator, a district
superintendent,
principal, et cetera,
saying, OK, I want to
do this for my school,
and then kind of layering
your programs on?
JEFF WETZLER: What we
actually have found
is that it needs to be both.
So it doesn't work if
it's only top-down,
because people,
quote, "at the top"
don't have the kind of
insights and direct experience
and proximity that's
needed to do that.
So a lot of the
experiences that we foster,
particularly on
when we're trying
to build demand and
readiness for this,
directly involve
educators, directly involve
parents, et cetera.
But folks at the top
create the conditions
to make this possible, as well.
And so typically, when we do
an engagement with someone,
we are also working with the
CEO or the superintendent
or different things like
that to create the cover
and create the permission
for people to innovate.
I'll take this.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious, in
the research that you've done
and implementation,
have you found
that you need to have a
radical approach to cutting out
the current system and trying
to replace it with the goals
that you'd listed?
Or do you think there's a way
to do it incrementally that just
builds upon the current
system but moves it slowly
towards the goals
that you've listed?
JEFF WETZLER: So when
we first started,
we had kind of a purist
ideological approach.
It was like, you had to take
out a blank sheet of paper,
you had to leave
it all behind, you
had to design fresh, et cetera.
And we do still
believe that you really
do need to think about
the total environment.
It's like if you were
taking a horse and buggy
and you were trying to say, how
do we put an engine on that?
It's just not going to work.
You need to think holistically.
But over time, as we've
worked with schools
and seen these different
kind of models, what we've
come to appreciate is
that there's really
a lot of power and
components of school.
So I don't just mean what we'd
call a point solution, just
like one curriculum.
But if you can take
a significant part
of a kid's experience or
an adult's experience,
start with that.
That can make real change.
And that can then open
the door to what's
the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing.
And pretty soon,
over several years,
you can stack together things.
And you step back
and you say, wow,
that's a radically
different environment.
But it didn't require gutting
it all from the start.
I appreciate the question.
AUDIENCE: Kind of
following up on that,
how do you think about
the broader picture of,
I like this idea of innovating
and changing and making it more
individual for kids, but what
do you think about the system--
schools are meant to gear
towards test-- standardized
testing and getting
into college.
How do you think this type--
how do you explain
that, I guess,
as you convince schools
to incorporate this in,
knowing that eventually
these kids need to work
towards these types of tests?
JEFF WETZLER: Yeah.
So we can't ignore that.
The stakes for kids
are real in terms
of what you get on the SAT, and
can you get access to college,
and can you get access to
jobs, and things like that.
So nothing that
we're trying to do
is trying to say we should
ignore that, we should pretend
those things don't
exist, particularly
when the playing field is
not level for all kids.
Really, kids having
opportunities deeply, deeply
matters.
So part of the way
we think about it
is that even if we were
just trying to optimize
within the current system,
lots of these kinds of designs
can increase motivation, can
be more efficient for learning,
et cetera, and just
kind of optimize
within that current system.
And then at the same time,
there's a number of efforts
underway to think about
measures of things
that go beyond the traditional
standardized tests,
whether those are
social-emotional development,
critical thinking, other
kinds of future-of-work types
of competencies.
And so that work really
needs to continue.
And as that work
gets more legitimized
and gets more momentum, I
think it will open up lots
more pathways for kids, too.
AUDIENCE: So I know you--
kind of jumping off
of her question,
you're focusing a lot on
the education system, which
is really nice, obviously.
But I feel like
there's problems that
exist kind of at
the workforce level,
where people are judged
off of pieces of paper
with certain scores or
what school you went to
and stuff like that.
Is there a way to kind of hit
this problem from both ends?
Instead of just saying, let's
get these educators better
and make sure the students
are better so that they can
get a job, but
instead, also say,
hey, let's try to hire people
in a way that's not necessarily
just standardized, either?
JEFF WETZLER: It
absolutely matters.
And I think Google is
among the leaders in kind
of pushing on that
question and saying,
let's not just look at
traditional transcripts
or where'd you go to school
or that kind of thing,
but what are the skills?
But the more that people
follow that lead and do that,
I think the more that
opens up the possibility
for the K12 system
of schools to feel
even more confident in
expanding its range of outcomes
that it's going for, as well.
I'll leave you with this quote.
"If you always do
what you always did,
you'll always get
what you always got."
I think we've talked a
lot about why that's not
good enough for kids and for
society and for workplaces,
as well.
And if there's one
message I would
want to have you take
away, it's possible to do
something different.
If we design the
system one way, we
can design the
system another way.
It takes R&D. It takes capacity.
It takes all the things that you
all do in the work that you do.
But it's really possible.
And that's what
we're trying to do.
We would love help in all kinds
of different kinds of ways
and people to get involved.
So there's a website
up here and whatever.
If you want to get
involved, please join us.
It's going to take all
of us to get this done.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]